sound effects
[Music]
so I've been doing some research and in
Game of Thrones one of the biggest shows
ever is coming out with a prequel what
do I need to do to get on that show the
ants are simple I need to become a
knight
where can you become a knight you ask
well the answer is medieval values so
I'm gonna go to medieval times I'm gonna
learn how to fight with swords I'm gonna
choreograph an entire fight sequence
film it and then send it to casting Game
of Thrones here I come
okay so here's the plan we are driving
some medieval times right now I have a
nice little crew here people are gonna
help me and I got all these people
together sound people pas producers a
day right here is a producer he actually
um he's coming with me because he wants
to learn how to he just wants to leave
the office and learn how to fight like
me in a day we'll learn the basics and
how to fight and like different
techniques in what stage combat really
is and then we're gonna work with the
Knights to choreograph a scene that
makes sense for the fight so I'm gonna
fight a day ultimately that's the goal
for the scene but if a day sucks I am
going to fire him what yes and I'll
replace them with one of the Knights
from medieval times you then by no way
what you just do it then I don't know I
don't understand you jersey highways you
miss one exit you get sent back
so now we're running late we have less
time to shoot that's strike one
and more strikes you're fired
[Music]
[Music]
this is really how's it going oh you can
is it like this okay good to meet you
Eric I'm Kyle and a day nice to meet you
you're a night amazing so I'm trying to
prove to Casting that I can be a knight
okay do you think I have what it takes
to be a knight well we're gonna find out
when it comes down to it it's all about
character okay you have to have a very
deep appreciation for what you do and
you have to have a very dedicated spirit
to make it through it's a dangerous job
obviously we're sword fighting these are
real metal weapons and we're swinging
them at each other so the physical
aspect of it is important but what
actually drives you is more important
what is that exactly
it could be anything you're just gonna
find it inside yourself I'm just noting
it in your ass yeah this is called Leon
Gardens so we basically have three
strikes head
leg shoulder those are the basic strikes
let me try the three strikes real quick
now you're gonna bring it back here and
then you're gonna step forward again and
then strike the leg okay
[Music]
keep each other safe if you're striking
you actually have to stop there so I'm
gonna do this you don't come in my box
I'll go in your box
it's when I'm blocking I'm gonna block
like this I'm gonna block like this
that's I never block like this and all
their strikes stop at the end of the box
okay I'm doing a strike can you do this
I don't want to do that yeah we gotta
brows so you're gonna take him train
them hit like this that is heavy hmm
good open up your hips a little bit up
and over step just look there's a rhythm
to it you'll find it you can kind of see
the guys doing over there one two one
two keep your hands in front of your
face and open up there's two sides to
the fight one guy's blocking like that
striking I'll be learning the strikes
walks this training regimen it's hard to
grasp like I'm trying my best
there's like so many moves the blocking
you got really make sure you keep the
sword away from you and you have the
power and this isn't like easy this
sweat coming down my head I don't know
if you can see this a day how are you
doing
sucking don't worry about it we're
getting there baby steps man I know you
guys do this we've had football players
baseball players that are really fit
people come in here and they start dying
yeah it takes a whole different skill
set to learn okay quick check-in while
the days gone I guess he hasn't been
practicing honestly do you think a day
is reading the news hmm honestly okay
I'm just gonna fight it with a little
bit more practice we can't have two
average people fighting the scene and
it'd look good and if they just wanted
to get into the office and he had a good
time learning exactly put all your style
this is Justin hey he's a very talented
director that I invited last minute to
come and help direct this scene because
I really wanted to look good I'm gonna
go get change now thank you right thank
you guys
[Music]
yeah that or decide you beat me in a
fight and then I asked to walk away
ashamed I'd rather die
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]